mais lundi matin
aux journées qui commencent pas mal de
choses à faire et à voir entre un enfant
elle et direction paris parce que tu as
mal là-bas ensuite je lancement awake
plus à l'ombre maléfique affaire
aujourd'hui au programme de visites
sympa il y a aussi produit à récupérer
il ya des gouverneurs il ya pas mal de
se réfère première chose qu'on jette
dans ce train
[Musique]
tu es 2 2
pour tout type numéro ailleurs récupéré
du match up
je trouve ça génial merci
[Musique]
tu le
bon allez aujourd'hui on a pas mal de
trucs à voir
[Musique]
non
ceux qui sont arrivés au studio
aujourd'hui c'est quoi ça comme créneau
chine je vous dirai pas pour casser m'a
replacé les smartphones qui sont très
bons on fait ça on en parle très très
très bientôt parce que ça s'essouffle
ça c'est toujours mario je vais pas vous
en parler par moments au peuple
alors ça je voulais déjà montré son
décor prix nocive pour les iphone parce
qu'on va se faire le test des iphone
très très très prochainement
ça c'est 80 que je ramène ici pour faire
le test et bientôt ça c'est le one plus
cette théorie on a parlé on va en
reparler très très prochainement là on a
eu deux iphone donc savons vous
connaissez déjà parlé ça c'est un cadeau
qui n'a fait romain de la chaîne techno
zone test merci romain and not
j'adore sa marque très écolo magnifique
designer meute
on a essayé ça pas mal
ayotte filmmaker bots you tube sans
oublier la casquette sont bons qui moi
mais je pense un petit peu vendre
quelque chose dans sa chance moi j'ai
une petite tête comme ça choix de boules
en main et cool packaging ça c'est le
nouveau moniteur du studio de philips 4k
uhd 3840 par deux mille cent soixante
militants on va être pas mal avec ça
plutôt cool ce truc là ça me permettra
de booster ça ça va partir là-bas jobs
côté et ensuite on a ce produit là c'est
la samsung galaxy watch est actif deux
alors j'aurais dit représenter la watch
actifs sains
la waci actif de l a été présenté il ya
assez peu de temps et on va se l'ouvrir
on va regarder ce cas dans cette boîte
aujourd'hui on veut juste faire une
option sera le test très très très
prochainement je vais enlever ma
fossiles de cinquième génération je vais
m celle là à la place
mais avant toute chose on regarde un
petit peu comment les fenêtres si le
packaging est bien fait bien bossé
sachez en tout cas que les mondes de
symptômes sont vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool j'ai fait la watch active
un que je trouvais intéressante site où
j'étais très très amoureux de la samsung
galaxy watch on va voir en tout cas ce
que dit cette fois des actifs de jack
packaging ont plutôt bien on reste
vraiment dans l'univers et dans
l'écosystème de 2,5 font de ce qu'ils
savent faire plutôt sympa comme
packaging on a toutes les infos de base
sur le dessus ça ça marche pour l'ouvrir
tiroirs ok donc déjà un premier niveau
de lecture comme ça on voit
effectivement que ces mots ça nous
reprend le bracelet c'est plutôt sympa
c'est original
j'imagine qu'on va regarder sur la
montre pas encore pas tout à fait on la
voit un petit peu design et là on arrive
sur
en outre à ok donc là j'arrive
uniquement sur le cadre attendez je
prends commence à ce que ce truc
j'avais tiré là bien qu'ils aient salima
d'elle
j'aime beaucoup sur le principe ce côté
de métal chromé brillant très classe
comme ça il ya un côté vraiment vraiment
vraiment classieux de boutons qui sont
relativement différent bien là ça doit
être j'imagine le micro ici j'ose
imaginer que ça va être le brass les yes
ok là on a un bracelet cuir donc assez
classe ça c'est assez kalisa ce côté
cuir là dessus comme ça ça n'aurait pas
été vraiment extrêmement premium le côté
cuir comme ça on retrouve tout le côté
chrome et brillant on n'a pas encore
allumé mais comme ça déjà c'est vraiment
très très sympa ensuite à l'intérieur
ici qu'est ce qu'on attend peut-être lui
qui est venu en premier ici on va voir
pour le recharger tout simplement déjà c
c est vanté le twin sheet s'auto
alimente sa taxe s'est posée comme ça
s'est posée c'est une lente et pas trop
jouer c'est quand même un petit peu
lourd
ça vient comme ça là on retrouve
effectivement avec de l'usb est ici
qu'est ce qu'on va voir
lui veut pas venir on est comme jamais
comme ça coince tape guide j la carte de
garantie bon voila j'ai les infos les
infos de base si vous avez envie de
faire la lecture ça c'est vachement
agréable ses brasseries en cuir comme ça
pour venir la tâche et c'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus qu'ali que quand on
a des bracelets en silicone alors
comparé à sa silicon c'est idéal pour
aller faire du sport mais le bracelet en
cuir pour le côté un petit peu plus
qu'un jour le côté un peu plus mode
classieux ça c'est pas mal du tout
samsung galaxy ou h active de ces partis
démarrez l'application galaxie wearable
sur votre téléphone galaxy wearable
desmarais galaxy ou attractive de
motorisation j'autorise j'autorise
j'autorise j'autorise passons à
l'association s appuyer pour vous
connecter
finir la configuration sur le téléphone
est un plugin installé c'est le
permettra le transfert de notre votre
montrer votre téléphone
ok j'installe le plugin prestations pour
votre nouvel appareil galaxie votre
actif deux accepté tout va bien jacques
c'est jack c'est jack c'est de toute
façon si je veux que ça marche il vaut
mieux accepter
j'accepte tout sauf les infos commercial
la connexion à mon compte samsung s'est
terminée profiter en mettant de votre
montre plus
la poussée à fond j'ai tous mes
paramètres sur le haut peut venir
naviguer entre les paramètres c'est
vachement cool je reviens là sur le base
et quoi sur le bas j'ai rien ici de ce
côté gêné email les infos toutes les
notifications sur la droite activités
quotidiennes là quelques-uns prix
probablement mais à qui préférait le
sport cardio 99 bpm tout va bien je suis
au top
la météo au quai j'autorise calendrier
au portel et widgets ça c'est cool
donc si je clique lasse assez pour
revenir en arrière si j'ai bien compris
job en arrière et là en bas cessons
toutes mes applications
bon moi je la trouve plutôt court en
tout cas cette galaxie watch active de
design qui est bien bien fait beau
bracelet en j'imagine que le bracelet
bien évidemment on peut lui changer vite
car plusieurs brasser dans la gamme par
contre ce cadre on veut te trouve très
beau je pense que ça sent le côté chats
ou pense que le petit trou là ça c'est
un micro a l'air pas mal je ce que je
fais c'est que je la teste pendant
quelques jours je prends le temps qu'un
habitué je regarde ce qui marche qui
marche pas si l interface d amel un
ancien intéressante oui non et je vous
dit tout d'ici là je vous invite à venir
vous ce que vous avancez comment vous la
trouvez en bas en commentaire ce que
c'est une montre qui pourrait vous
bottez vous plaire est ce que vous êtes
me connecter ou instruments prêter c'est
pas du tout du tout votre truc
je vous en parle de plus en vie parce
que je trouve que c'est un des
accessoires que on a plus avec nous
d'autres smartphones bien évidemment
mais une jolie monde connecté au poignet
ça marche toujours
et c'est très pratique des fois on ne
peut pas sortir son smartphone on est en
réunion ont dit non courants nés où on
veut et c'est important de regarder vous
à tous pour votre monde c'est vraiment
vraiment cool il ya vraiment des
produits qui viennent de plus en plus
beau moi j'aime bien sur le principe je
trouve plutôt cool lâche porter jusqu'à
ya pas longtemps la possible de
cinquième génération que je trouve très
bien au niveau de l'autonomie
on va voir si la galaxie où à chaque
type 2 peut lui faire de longs ou pas du
tout ou alors on verra voilà prête donc
abonnez-vous dès maintenant si vous
voulez tout savoir sur ce je vous fais
des gros
vous et vous donne rendez vous dès
demain et surtout restez connectés
abonnez-vous parce que dans quelques
jours va y avoir plein nouveautés plein
de nouveaux produits des tests plein de
nouvelles choses là n'oublie pas d'un
carton on a un produit qui est sous
embargo dont on parle très prochainement
je dis d'ailleurs pour tout vous dire
voilà bisous chaos